Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Nach Moon Knight und Ms. Marvel
kommt mit She-Hulk
jetzt die 3. MCU-Serie dieses Jahres
bei Disney+.
Da sehen wir Jennifer Waters.
Die hadert extrem zwischen
einem Leben als normale Anwältin
und ihren krassen Verwandlungen
in ein grünes Muskelpaket.
Ihre Kräfte hat sie
durch eine Blutspende bekommen,
von einem Verwandten,
den wir gut kennen, dem Hulk.
Aber funktioniert das in Echt?
Also könnte der Hulk
seine Kräfte per Blutspende,
ähm, also Wutspende
an Jennifer übertragen?
Das checken wir jetzt.
Wir machen dabei ein DNA-Experiment,
das ihr zu Hause nachmachen könnt.
Also, los geht's.
Als Comic-Figur
gibt es She-Hulk seit über 40 Jahren.
Da wird erklärt,
wie sie zu She-Hulk wurde.
In der 1. Ausgabe,
"The Savage She-Hulk", von 1980,
ist sie mit zufällig
ihrem Cousin Bruce Banner unterwegs.
Sie wird angeschossen
und droht, zu verbluten.
Bruce erinnert sich, dass Jennifer
die gleiche Blutgruppe hat wie er.
Er gibt ihr eine Bluttransfusion.
Und damit auch sein "Gamma-Gene".
Per Comic-Erklärung
sind das die Gene,
die hierfür verantwortlich sind.
Woanders erfahren wir von Spiderman,
dass sich diese Gamma-Gene
an Blutzellen binden.
Sie können so per Transfusion
übertragen werden.
Ist diese Erklärung plausibel?
Das wollen wir genauer wissen.
Dazu haben wir uns
die Molekularbiologin
und YouTuberin Rebecca dazugeholt.
Können Gene wirklich
so einzeln im Blut rumschwimmen?
Hey, Jack, nein,
normalerweise tun sie das nicht.
Gene sind nämlich Abschnitte
in der DNA.
Wenn wir so eine DNA-Doppelhelix
vor uns haben,
ist etwa dieser Abschnitt ein Gen.
Die können
unterschiedlich lang sein.
Es ist nicht so, dass es genau
ein Gen für ein Merkmal gibt:
Wir haben 25.500 Gene
bei uns im Körper.
Allein für die Haarfarbe
sind 124 zuständig.
Gene kommen also nicht
als Einzelteile vor.
Sie sind in der DNA gebunden
und die sitzt im Zellkern.
Also, dass diese Gamma-Gene
frei umherschwimmen
und irgendwie ans Blut andocken,
wie Peter Parker beschreibt,
ist unrealistisch.
Es müsste wenn,
dann Gamma-DNA heißen.
Die ist eigentlich im Zellkern.
Aber DNA kann tatsächlich
frei umherschwirren,
wenn man sie isoliert.
Das klingt etwas technisch,
ist aber gar nicht kompliziert.
Das ist sogar so simpel,
dass wir es hier machen können.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so rein
wie im Labor, aber es funktioniert.
Ihr könnt es sogar
zu Hause nachmachen.
Ich zeige euch, wie es geht.
Kommt also mit in ...
... ♪ Jack's Experimentierküche.
Hallo, wir werden jetzt
DNA extrahieren.
Das macht sich besonders gut
mit Pflanzenzellen.
Darum habe ich geeignete Obst-
und Gemüsesorten mitgebracht.
Und wenn wir She-Hulk drehen,
nehmen wir eine schöne grüne Kiwi.
Die schneiden wir auf,
und geben das Fruchtfleisch
in eine Schüssel.
Dann reißen wir die Zellen
aus ihrem festen Verbund auseinander,
mit einem Mixer.
Als nächstes stellen wir uns
einen Extraktionspuffer her.
Das klingt kompliziert, ist aber
nur ein Mix aus 50 ml Zitronensaft,
50 ml Wasser ...
... einem halben Teelöffel Salz ...
... und ... Spülmittel.
10 ml davon.
Warum ist da Spülmittel
und Zitronensaft drin?
Die beiden sind gute Putzmittel.
Als solches müssen sie v.a.
eines können: Fette lösen.
Das brauchen wir,
um die DNA rauszubekommen.
Die ist von mehreren Fettschichten
umgeben: von der Zellhülle
und von der Hülle des Zellkerns.
Die brechen wir damit auf
und lösen die DNA raus.
Wir kippen
die beiden Sachen zusammen.
Dann kann die Magie beginnen.
*jazzige Musik*
Die Experimente-Küche brodelt!
Hier ist etwas passiert:
Die DNA hat sich im Wasser gelöst.
Zum Weitermachen nehmen wir
ein Sektglas und Kaffeefilter
und kippen das Gemisch
durch den Filter durch.
Es reicht, wenn hier im Glas etwa
10 ml filtrierte Flüssigkeit sind.
Da gebe wir noch mal
10 ml Wasser dazu.
Dann kommt
der eiskalte Brennspiritus.
DNA ist in Wasser gut löslich,
in Alkohol aber nicht.
In Alkohol aber nicht.
Der sorgt dafür,
dass sie ausfällt und verklumpt.
Yes!
Wenn man hier mit einem Spieß
so langsam umrührt, dann seht ihr:
Das, was da dran hängen bleibt,
ist ein echtes Knäuel
aus ganz viel DNA.
Wir haben hier
unsere aufgewickelten Gene.
Jetzt ist die Frage: Wenn wir so tun,
als wäre das die Gamma-Gene
bzw. die Gamma-DNA,
was würde passieren, wenn ich mir die
in mein Blut injiziere?
Ich würde jetzt gern
was Spektakuläres sagen,
aber die Realität ist:
Dein Körper
würde die fremde DNA abbauen
und die Nährstoffe wiederverwenden.
Denn unser Körper ist das beste
Recyclingcenter, was es gibt.
Das macht der Körper auch
mit seinen eigenen Zellen.
Man sagt, alle paar Jahre
sind wir neue Menschen.
Das ist, weil sich die Zellen
ständig erneuern.
Zellen haben eine Art
Selbstmordprogramm eingebaut,
die "Apoptose".
Wenn Zellen merken,
sie sind unbrauchbar oder zu alt,
lösen sie das sogar selbst aus.
Sie schrumpfen
und lösen sich aus dem Gewebe.
Damit dieser Müll aufgeräumt wird,
kommt eine Fresszelle vorbei
und löst die Zellbestandteile auf.
Sie nutzt Enzyme,
um die DNA abzubauen
und das Ganze wird recycelt.
Das würde auch passieren,
wenn fremde DNA oder fremde
DNA-Teile in die Blutbahn kommen.
Man kann zusammenfassen:
Gamma-Gene oder Gamma-DNA
einfach lose im Blut
würden bei einer Transfusion
gar nichts anrichten.
Jennifers Körper
würde das einfach abbauen.
Und She-Hulk damals
leider nicht existieren.
Oh...
Lass uns davon ausgehen,
dass Spiderman da
was falsch verstanden hat.
Und diese Gamma-Gene
nicht frei im Blut umherschwirren.
Sondern ein Teil der DNA
von Bruce Banners Zellen sind.
Im MCU, im Film
"Der unglaubliche Hulk"
sehen wir auch, dass der mutierte
rote Blutkörperchen hat, also grüne.
Aber könnten die Gene dann
per Bluttransfusion
an Jennifer weitergegeben werden?
Dafür müssen wir uns Blut angucken.
Blut besteht ca. zur Hälfte
aus Blutplasma, dem flüssigen Teil,
und zur anderen Hälfte
aus Blutzellen.
Die sind speziell.
99% dieser Zellen
sind rote Blutkörperchen.
Würden wir die verändern,
weil sie so zahlreich vorkommen,
hätte das einen krassen Effekt.
Das Problem an der Sache:
Sie haben keinen Zellkern.
Und damit auch keine DNA.
Sie sind somit für unseren Vergleich
unbrauchbar und sofort raus.
Selbst wenn die mutiert sind
und grüne Blutkörperchen werden,
könnte Bruce Banner auf jeden Fall
nicht seine Gene weitergeben.
Die restlichen 1% sind Blutplättchen
und weiße Blutkörperchen.
Die Blutplättchen sind auch raus,
sie haben keinen Zellkern.
Aber die weißen Blutkörperchen
haben einen Zellkern und auch DNA.
Wenn die Gamma-Gene
übertragen werden sollen,
dann müsste es
mit den weißen Blutkörperchen sein.
Das wäre heute im echten Leben
gar nicht easy.
In dieser 80er-Jahre-Szene
bekam Jennifer das gesamte Blut
von ihrem Cousin übertragen.
Heute ist es Standard,
dass nach einer Transfusion das Blut
in seine Bestandteile zerlegt wird.
Damit Patient*innen,
die diese Bestandteile brauchen,
immer nur den Teil
des Blutes bekommen,
der für die Behandlung notwendig ist.
Jennifer würde wahrscheinlich
keine weißen Blutkörperchen bekommen.
Die werden nur sehr selten
bei Transfusionen übergeben,
in ganz speziellen Krankheitsfällen.
Wenn wir noch mal zurück
in die 80er-Jahre gehen,
zu dieser Backstory,
dann haut das schon ungefähr hin.
Zum einen gab es in den 80er-Jahren
noch Vollblut-Transfusionen.
Zum anderen machen die das da
"quick and dirty" zu Hause.
Deshalb ist es schon plausibel,
dass sie mit dem Blut
von Bruce Banner
auch seine Gene übertragen bekommt.
Aber wir müssen noch mal
Rebecca fragen.
Also, DNA lose ins Blut injiziert
macht gar nichts.
Aber wie ist das
mit weißen Blutkörperchen und DNA?
Was soll ich sagen,
die können Jennifer
auch nicht genetisch verändern.
Weiße Blutkörperchen
"leben" nur noch 8 Tage im Körper.
Sie können sich
nicht mehr vermehren.
Das gilt für alle Blutzellen
in unserem Körper.
Blutzellen werden im Knochenmark
aus Stammzellen hergestellt.
Wenn so eine Zelle
zur Blutzelle geworden ist,
haben sie ihr Endstadium
schon erreicht.
Die weißen Blutkörperchen sind also
nach spätestens 8 Tagen wieder weg.
Und Jennifer hat wieder ihre eigenen
weißen Blutkörperchen hergestellt.
Selbst wenn es andere Zellen wären,
würde ihr Körper
eine Immunreaktion starten.
Und mit Fieber, Antikörper
und Fresszellen
den Eindringling bekämpfen.
Fun Fact: Das passiert auch, wenn
bei einer Wunde etwas eindringt,
wie etwa ein Holzsplitter.
Ein Holzsplitter besteht
zu großen Teilen aus Pflanzenzellen.
Da kommen unsere Fresszellen dazu
und versuchen, diese abzubauen.
Zusammen mit dem Fremdkörper
bilden unsere Fresszellen den Eiter.
Okay ... das ist ja richtig ...
... "fun", ähm.
Das ist also gar nicht so selten,
dass sich fremde Zellen
und so fremde DNA
bei uns einschleichen?
Im Gegenteil,
das ist sogar die Regel.
In unserem Körper
gibt es genauso viele
bis doppelt so viele Bakterien
wie eigene Zellen.
Das heißt, ihr besteht zu mindesten
50 Prozent aus fremder DNA.
Aber, und das ist auch wichtig
für She-Hulk:
Nur weil sie da sind,
heißt das nicht,
unsere DNA wird verändert.
Damit können wir hier mit einem
gängigen Comic-Irrglauben aufräumen:
Dass ein kleiner DNA-Eintrag
in einen Körper
sofort den gesamten
Organismus verändert.
Wie etwa in Sam Raimis
Spiderman-Film:
Da wird Peter Parker von einer
radioaktiven Spinne gebissen.
Und zack, sofort ist die DNA
in allen Zellen
auf die gleich Art und Weise mutiert.
Das ist totaler Quatsch.
Nicht falsche verstehen,
natürlich gibt es "Mutagene".
Also äußere Einwirkungen,
die eine Genmutation auslösen können.
Ja, dazu zählt auch Strahlung.
Aber Mutagene wirken sich immer nur
lokal auf einzelne Zellen aus.
Und vor allem nicht zwingend
auf alle betroffenen Zellen
in der gleichen Art und Weise.
Darum gibt uns Radioaktivität
leider keine Superkräfte.
Das haben wir schon besprochen.
Die Folge verlinke ich euch hier.
Also, She-Hulk hat die Gamma-Gene
bei Transfusion nicht einzeln
übertragen bekommen.
Und auch nicht
über weiße Blutkörperchen.
Es muss etwas anderes
in Hulks Blut gewesen sein,
das Jennifer Walters zu She-Hulk
hat werden lassen.
Es gibt noch eine Möglichkeit.
Es gibt Fremdkörper,
die per Blut übertragen werden können
und teils auch ewig
im Körper verbleiben.
Das sind bestimmte Viren.
Viren sind keine Zellen und
technisch gesehen nicht mal Lebewesen.
Das haben wir schon in
der "Resident Evil"-Folge besprochen.
Sie sind nur Erbgut in einer Hülle.
Darum haben sie nur die Chance,
sich zu vermehren und verbreiten,
indem sie in einem Körper
eine Wirtszelle befallen.
Sie gaukeln der Zelle vor,
sie seien der Zellkern.
Die Zelle sagt dann, okay,
und produziert aus sich selbst heraus
plötzlich neue Viren.
Das sieht man hier gut.
Das ist eine
Raster-Elektronen-Mikroskop-Aufnahme
vom Uniklinikum in Jena.
Das Gesamte hier
ist ein Teil einer Zelle.
Die einzelnen Kullern sind frisch
produzierte Corona-Viren,
die gerade
aus der Zellmembran austreten.
Eine Zelle ist nach diesem Prozess
relativ unbrauchbar.
Sie stirbt ab, und die Viren
verbreiten sich weiter im Körper.
Bis sie bestenfalls
vom Immunsystem gestoppt werden.
Ein Beispiel, was zu She-Hulk passt,
sind Herpes-Viren.
Es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Sie werden teils
über Blut übertragen.
Wenn die einen Körper befallen,
erkennt und bekämpft sie
das Immunsystem.
Aber einige Viren schaffen es,
in die Nervenzellen vorzudringen
und sich dort zu "verstecken".
Das kann ein Leben lang sein.
Wenn die Abwehrkräfte zu einem
gewissen Zeitpunkt geschwächt sind,
können solche Viren dann ausbrechen.
Sie attackieren etwa eure Lippen
und geben euch diese fiesen Bläschen.
Die Krankheit kommt also nur
in bestimmten Situationen vor.
Das passt zu dem,
was Spiderman gesagt hat:
Die Gene heften sich
an bestimmte Zellen.
Aber diese Gene sind nicht
Bruce Banners Erbinformationen,
sondern die Erbinformationen
dieser Viren.
She-Hulk kann ihre Verwandlung
kontrollieren: über Wut.
Da muss uns Rebecca
noch mal aushelfen.
Das passt doch in Teilen
auch auf diese Herpes-Analogie?
Wie She-Hulk ihre Kräfte,
kann man einen Herpes-Ausbruch
nicht kontrollieren.
Aber speziell bei Herpes
gibt es Studien, die andeuten,
dass Stress und besonders Ekel
das Virus wieder ausbrechen lassen.
In diesem Paper von der Uni Trier
haben Forschende
Studien-Teilnehmenden
erst Fotos von dreckigen Gläsern
und dann
die dreckigen Gläser gezeigt.
48 Stunden später hatten 4 von 10
Teilnehmenden ein Herpes-Bläschen.
In der Kontrollgruppe niemand.
Wenn ein Ausbruch da ist,
vermehren sich die Viren rapide.
Das, was man am Ende rausbekommt,
also die Superkraft,
die übrig bleibt,
ist leider ein Zellschaden.
Aber es zeigt:
Wenn Ekel Herpes auslösen kann,
ist es gar nicht so unplausibel,
dass eine andere Emotion
wie Wut die Hulk-Gene triggert.
Und damit She-Hulk verwandelt.
She-Hulk weiß genau,
was sie wütend macht,
wenn sie eine Verwandlung braucht.
Das ist Politik,
horrende Uni-Kredite
und die Basketballer
von den New York Knicks.
Bei mir wären es Montage.
Ich hasse Montage.
Aber was sind
eure She-Hulk-Triggergedanken?
Was macht euch so richtig sauer?
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare.
Was haben wir heute gelernt?
Der Hulk kann seine Gene
nicht so einfach über Bluttransfusion
an seine Cousine übergeben.
Also nicht so,
dass es einen Effekt hat.
Was er weitergeben kann,
ist eine Virusinfektion.
Wenn das nicht nett ist!
Wenn also aus Gamma-Genen
Gamma-Viren werden.
Dann haut das auch
mit der Backstory hin,
dass She-Hulk ihre Kräfte
an- und ausschalten kann.
Danke an Becky fürs Erklären.
Flitz doch mal zu ihrem Kanal
und lasst etwas Liebe von uns da.
Habt ihr schon
in She-Hulk reingeschaut?
Wie gefällt euch die neue Serie?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
Vergesst nicht,
den Kanal zu abonnieren,
die Glocke zu drücken,
dann sehen wir uns bald wieder, ciao.
Copyright MDR 2022
UT: S. Asperger